et pour en parler monsieur camille sari
économiste et président de l'institut
euro maghrébin d'étude et de prospective
également auteur du livre l'algérie
histoire secrète d'un naufrage annoncé
aux éditions l'harmattan nous a rejoint
bonjour monsieur sarine merci d'avoir
été notre invitation alors tout d'abord
quelle est votre réaction après ce
verdict c'est tout à fait attendue et
logique
non pas que ce soit un jugement je porte
pas de jugement sur le caractère je
dirais à dépendre de la justice
algérienne qui ne l'est pas et
l'histoire nous a montré que l elle
fonctionne par injonction et selon les
intérêts du pouvoir en place
je m'explique actuellement et au vu que
ce le irak c'est à dire cette révolution
se poursuit
il aurait été vraiment impensable qu'ils
aient à un allègement de jugement ou une
libération
à l'exception de louisa hanoune qui a
été libéré mais il a été quand même
condamné le conteste sa condamnation et
marron à l'impro c'est en fait son parti
un dénonce un procès politique à un
politique un verdict arrangé qu'est-ce
que oui oui tout à fait il est politique
est arrogé la concernant mais par contre
les faits qui ont été reprochés à said
bouteflika aux deux généraux
anciennement directeur des
renseignements généraux c'est à dire le
drs la direction du renseignement
algériens c'était les services secrets
il se sent bien réunis en mars
ils se sont réunis pour démettre donc le
général gaïd salah
parce que le général gaïd salah il
voulait
il a demandé explicitement le départ de
bouteflika donc il a lâché bouteflika
rappelons l'histoire il a soutenu et
c'est le plus ancien chef d'état major
c'est bouteflika qu'il a fait c'est lui
qui l'a nommé alors qu'ils n'avaient pas
là pas eu et il n'avait pas d'après dé
la rsa hérarchie l'avait pas les
qualités pour ce faire et donc le bout
de cette bouteille saïd bouteflika a
effectivement fait appel au général
zeroual à la retraite du général zia
l'oise et roanne et elle a été président
de l'algérie pendant une période c'est
lui qui a qui est un peu concocté
concocté cette cette amnistie aux
islamistes et qui était juste qui a
dirigé le pays juste avant l'arrivée de
bouteflika le zeroual avait refusé et il
s'est exprimé il a dit que effectivement
cette réunion a eu lieu les faits
reprochés se sont vraiment il faut bien
sûr ils sont avérées donc b le
le mis-en-cause ccc said bouteflika est
le général tard tagué le général mediene
donc c'est impensable qu'ils soient
libérés aux mêmes qui est une analyse
mans dernier allègement des lots au vu
que le irak demande depuis longtemps de
la fin de ce régime vous l'avez dit le
dax ce mouvement de contestation va
bientôt fêter ses un an on voit que la
rue algérienne
est toujours en colère chaque vendredi
il ya des manifestations ça révèle quoi
dans cette dans ce mouvement c'est que
ça va continuer tant que le système
n'est pas n'est pas voilà complètement
nettoyé si je puis dire le les algériens
et les algériennes qui manifestent ils
savent très bien que leurs
revendications sont politiques mais ils
sont aussi et surtout économique c'est à
dire que tant qu'il n'y a pas un
changement du système il n'y a pas une
vraie démocratie avec des institutions
de contrôle une justice indépendante
donc le la corruption va se poursuivre
et les détournements de fonds vont se
poursuivre donc c'est leur avenir qui
est en jeu et l'avenir de leurs enfants
surtout que maintenant les études
confirment ce que j'ai écris depuis 2011
ou même avant même avant que les
réserves de gaz et de pétrole
ils sont en chute libre et on nous cache
l'année les autorités algériennes cache
le vrai là le l'épuisement des puits et
il n'y a pas de renouvellement de ses
puits ils nous sortent à chaque fois
l'argument qu'il ya là il ya de l'avenir
dans le gaz de schiste et le pétrole de
schiste et qui je rappelle c'est dans le
sud de l'algérie où il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'eau donc mon ami abderrahmane
mebtoul professeur à oran et spécialiste
des hydrocarbures a démontré que même
s'il y a un potentiel il sera difficile
de l'exploiter à des prix compétitifs et
je j'ai une manière de relancer
l'économie
donc il n'ya que l'économie et les elle
va vers vraiment un effondrement et une
femme des réserves de change qui
s'élèvent à 60 milliards
so cela l'algérie pourrait rentrer et
devrait rentrer ci a pas un miracle
c'est à dire une une découverte de puits
de gaz
parce que l'algérie ne peut pas compter
sur son potentiel industriel il n'y a
plus d'industrie secteur du pib
donc l'algérie va devenir un pays
endetté sous les fourches caudines du
fmi c'est à dire ce que l'algérie a
connu et que moi j'ai connu quand
j'accompagnais des entreprises
françaises en algérie à partir de 1986
et l'effondrement des cours en 88
ça a été dramatique on pouvait on
pouvait apporter seulement des
médicaments et quelques produits
alimentaires et donc tout ce qui est
bien de deux intermédiaires comme les
fils etc
pour le textile pouvait pas et effondré
donc l'industrie s'effondrer et
l'algérie maintenant va compter 50
millions d'habitants à l'horizon de 2030
l'algérie va devenir importatrice de gaz
parce que la consommation de gaz explose
et les puits et la production c'est ford
donc les manifestants savent que leur
avenir se joue dans la rue et que si
jamais ils cessent de manifester ils
vont avoir des d'abord des représailles
mais aussi donc un avenir sombre pour
eux pour leurs enfants et les
générations futures
donc ce sont des revendications les
cyclones et koné légitime et celui des
tic malus qu'on a connu dans les années
80 avec les islamistes c'est vraiment
des jeunes qui sont instruits qui le
taux d'alphabétisation de l'algérie a
beaucoup augmenté donc il ya une prise
de conscience des problèmes économiques
et politiques très bien tout cas merci
beaucoup monsieur camille sari d'avoir
répondu à nos questions gens parce que
vous êtes et sodomisée président de
l'institut euro maghrébin d'étude et de
prospective également auteur du livre
l'algérie histoire secrète d'un naufrage
annoncé aux éditions l'harmattan